en jartum las columnas de humo se elevan
sobre la ciudad una prueba de que La
tregua no sea respetado en medio de los
combates este médico está ocupado
examina a un paciente tumbado en el
pupitre de un estudiante esta pequeña
escuela se ha transformado en un
dispensario de campaña
la mayoría de los hospitales están fuera
de servicio y no podemos llegar a los
que aún funcionan por eso creamos estos
dispensarios de urgencias
trabaja con los medios que dispone está
rodeado de voluntarios que acogen y
atienden a los enfermos y heridos
víctimas del conflicto
estamos en primera línea y la mayoría de
las heridas están relacionadas con la
guerra con la guerra que hace
prácticamente imposible obtener
suministros médicos
los jarabes y las pastillas escasean en
las estanterías
estamos a todos los que tengan
medicamentos de sobra en casa a que no
los traigan a nosotros o a otra clínica
del campo
este equipo de voluntarios sabe que aún
tendrá que aguantar mucho tiempo La
tregua negociada por los mediadores
saudíes y estadounidenses se ha
prorrogado a cinco días aunque no sea
respetado ningún alto del fuego según
las ongs más de 1800 personas han muerto
en este mes y medio de